MARK: Our next speaker--
it's my pleasure to introduce
my former postdoc advisor, Jeff
Magee.
Jeff is a professor
at the Baylor
College of Medicine and a Howard
Hughes Medical Investigator.
And Jeff did his PhD at
Tulane and then moved
to Baylor College of Medicine
for his postdoc with Dan
Johnston, who was the chair
of my thesis committee.
And he took his first
faculty position at LSU.
And he was there until
Hurricane Katrina hit the city.
And then he moved briefly
to the University of Texas
at Austin, which
is where I met him
while I was a graduate
student, before starting
as one of the initial
faculty members
at Howard Hughes Medical
Institute's Janelia Research
Campus.
And then that's
where I joined him
as a postdoc 13 long years
ago, I'm sorry to say.
JEFF MAGEE: Really?
Wow.
MARK: I think it was 13, yeah.
So Jeff is a world
leader in the field
of hippocampal computation
and specifically
in subcellular dynamics.
And he's going to
talk to us today
about some incredible
recent work on memory
and learning in the hippocampus.
JEFF MAGEE: OK, thank you, Mark.
I'm going to need
a power adapter.
I didn't bring mine.
If we could-- I'm
going to need--
I don't see one up here.
I only got 30%.
Maybe I can make it, but the
pressure might overwhelm me.
Thank you.
Bartlett to the rescue.
MARK: That one work?
Oh, yeah.
JEFF MAGEE: All right, so
thank you, Mark, for that.
Thank you, Ila for
the invitation.
I'm excited about ICoN.
Attacking this problem at
multiple levels is really,
I think, an excellent way
to make some progress.
And so I would encourage
you to pursue that as
much as possible.
We try to work at
three different levels,
and I find it
really overwhelming.
So I think you had
six or seven there.
And so good luck with that.
But-- [LAUGHING]
Pointer, no pointer, OK.
All right, so I
spent a long time
working on dendrites
when Mark was in the lab.
That's pretty much all we did.
More recently, we're studying
it-- thank you, again,
Bartlett.
We're studying a different
function of dendrites, maybe.
Just for the pointer?
And OK, that's a problem.
But-- just for the
pointer, you think?
CREW: Oh, for the pointer.
JEFF MAGEE: Yeah.
Perfect, all right.
CREW: This works fine.
JEFF MAGEE: Two of them.
So yes, we're trying to increase
our understanding of how
brains learn, OK?
Again, no small task.
And we're sort of inching
our way along, hopefully,
systematically.
It's been thought
for a long time
that learning produces adaptive
changes in certain brain
regions.
And of course, those changes are
adaptive because they improve
the behavior of the animal.
And so it's also been thought--
or known for a long
time that those
changes in particular
brain regions
are produced by
alterations in the strength
of synaptic connections between
neurons in those regions.
And this synaptic
plasticity alters
the input-output
transformation there in a way
that improves the behavior.
So now I'm going to
just bring up two issues
that you could say
complicate this.
And the first is just
pure numbers, OK?
In the little mouse
hippocampal subregion
I'm going to talk about,
there are 6 billion synapses,
and of course, really
astronomical numbers
in our brains.
And so it brings
up the point, how
is it possible for these
synaptic plasticity mechanisms
to find the right
synapses and change them
appropriately all within a short
amount of time as possible?
And so this is one problem.
And the other one is probably
an even bigger issue, something
that you're all familiar with.
And that's what I've
labeled synapse depth.
And we'll just use this little
multilayer three-layer network
as an analogy here.
It's not a very good one,
but it'll serve the purpose.
Here's the input
layer at the bottom.
You think of sensory
input coming in here.
And then these
cells make synapses
on to the middle
or hidden layer.
And then the middle hidden
layer makes synapses
on the output layer, the output
of which drives some action.
So of course,
multilayer networks
are quite powerful
because they can
produce complex input-output
transformations.
The trick is, of course, how to
change these 6 billion synapses
in light of the fact that there
are 60 billion other synapses
and parameters downstream
of them, between them
and the output region,
whose output you're
trying to optimize by
changing the weights of all
of these synapses.
Of course, Hebbian plasticities
these aren't up to this task
because they're blind to all
of these downstream parameters,
OK?
What's needed is some
kind of additional signal
that brings back information
about these parameters
and helps assist this synaptic
plasticity process right here.
This is, of course, backprop
in artificial neural networks.
And suffice it to say that
it is completely unknown how
this works or what this
signal is in real brains.
OK, so that's what I'm
going to talk about,
is a little adaptive change in
hippocampal population activity
that occurs during a very simple
behavior, a simple learning
behavior in mice.
And then I'll point out
the synaptic plasticity
that's responsible for
this adaptive change.
And then we'll go
into some detail
about the properties of the
instructive signal that is
directing the plasticity, OK?
So here's the behavior.
We work in mice.
They're head-fixed mice.
Here's one, an old
one, back in the day
when Mark was with
us, from Seb Royer.
And you can see that this
mouse is on a treadmill.
The treadmill has got
some features on it.
And they're trained to run
a lap, about 2 meters, 180
centimeters, and stop and
lick their water reward.
Very, very, very simple,
but that's the learning.
That's what they learn, where
to run to, and stop, and lick.
And I'll show you some
behavioral data in a minute.
During this, we're going
to make one of either two
kinds of recordings,
the first I'll
show you, some
population recordings
from a set of about 300, 400
neurons pyramidal cells in CA1.
And you can see the
world famous place cells.
From six of these
shown here, you
can see that they
tile the environment.
Essentially, these
are calcium signals,
of course, that rise and
fall because the action
potential firing rate of
these cells rises and falls.
Here's one of these place
fields, just now in location.
And you can see the heat maps
of the place field, the firing
rate, if you will, for all
of these six neurons here.
And they've been sorted so
that they tile the environment.
You're going to see a lot of
these in the next 30 minutes.
So that's what they look like.
The activity has
been peak scaled.
OK, so here's the behavior.
It's very simple.
Christine is going to
have several days of sort
of pre-training,
where the animal's
on a belt that is blank.
It has none of these
somatosensory cues on it.
And the reward position on the
belt changes from lap to lap.
And you can see,
here's the licking.
Each one of these
little ticks is a lick.
And the animal's just
licking all over the place,
trying to find the reward.
And they're running at rather
a uniform, a constant yet slow
velocity across the track.
And here are a population
of 400 or so CA1 place
cells that are
recorded simultaneously
with this behavior.
And you can see,
again, they've been
sorted by the position
of their place field.
And there's a uniform tiling
of the entire environment.
Now, next day is learning day.
She changes the environment
by putting a bunch of cues
that you saw before
on the belt and fixes
the reward right in
the middle, here.
And you can see, the
evolution of the licking
is quite rapidly--
certainly, by 30, 40,
50 trials, the animal
has figured out where the reward
is and only licks right there.
That's the behavior, and it
occurs within 10 minutes.
And what also changes is
that the animal begins
to slow down and stop,
like you saw on the video,
around the reward,
to consume the reward
and then begins running again.
Now, we look at the same
set of animals, same fields,
microscope field, same neurons.
And we can see that
there's about two,
three times as many
place cells now
and that there's this
huge overrepresentation
at the reward side.
Again, nearly
three-fold increase
in the density of place
cells that have their place
fields around the reward.
OK, so there's an
experience-dependent shaping
of the representation.
A lot of other people study
this and have seen this before.
This group has seen that if they
do an optogenetic manipulation
that removes this
overrepresentation, then
this learning, this evolution
of licking also doesn't happen.
So we would call this
an adaptive change.
OK, so this is our adaptive
change in hippocampal activity.
Now, what's going on?
I told you there was
about two or three times
as many place fields
at the end of day
one as from the beginning.
And what's basically
happening is,
there are new place fields
appearing during the session.
And there are four
characteristics, four
or five characteristics
of these new place fields
that are relevant to what
I'm going to tell you.
And so the first is that-- you
can see here, they just sort of
pop out.
They appear abruptly.
So no real hints that there's
any kind of activity already
here.
They're not sort of
ramping up over time.
They just boom, appear.
And many people in
the hippocampal world
see place cells that do this.
Now the other thing is,
you'll see that they
tend to shift back in space.
In this case, we're in space.
So the first field is here.
And then on the
subsequent two or three,
it moves back and stays there.
And the same is here.
It moves back and
stays there, OK?
And so there's this predictive
shift, step back in space.
Next, you can
already see as well,
is that depending on the running
speed of the animal, when
the place field appears,
the width of the place field
changes as well.
The faster they run,
the wider the field
that's going to result, OK?
And finally, all of
this, and the development
of the overrepresentation,
and the increase
in the number of place cells,
all the adaptive changes
can be blocked by changes--
different drugs which block
plasticity in these regions,
like NMDA receptor antagonist.
And a blocker of R type
calcium channels or even
L type calcium channels will
remove these adaptive changes.
OK, so let's see.
So I don't really have time
to go into this too much.
I'm going to show
you quickly what
I'm talking about in a minute.
But synaptic plasticity, we
found over the past 10 years
or so that these place
fields are driven
by a synaptic plasticity, OK?
There's a ramp of depolarization
of the membrane potential that
crosses threshold and produces
then action potential firing
at a particular location.
That ramp of depolarization is
produced by an enhanced weight
of the synaptic input, the
excitatory synaptic input
that's coming in.
OK, so I'm going to show
you one example and then
a little bit of population data,
and then cut to the cartoon.
It's unfortunate,
but if you'd like
to talk to me more detail
about it, I'd be happy to.
All right, so this
is the other way
that we record
from these animals,
and that is wholesale
voltage recordings
while the animal's doing
the same thing that
have already showed you.
What's going to happen
is, the animal is
going to be running these laps.
And here's the VM.
And then the position of
the animal from 0 to 180
centimeters is in red.
And then there's an
extracellular voltage
that's been filtered at
theta band frequencies.
A dendritic calcium spike,
dendritic calcium plateau
potential is going to
occur on one trial.
And then in the
next trial, there'll
be a place field there.
And these plateau
potentials occur out
in the distal apical dendrite.
So here we go.
I'm going to hold it down
to make it go twice as fast.
You can see there's one lap.
There's essentially
no place field there.
And this is the animal standing.
Nothing's going on.
There's a little bit of firing
while the animal's standing.
And when it starts running,
there's a flat line on the VM.
We'll do one more.
Pre-lap, some firing while
the animal's standing.
And then, again, nothing.
And then on the
next trial, you'll
see plateau potential go off.
You'll notice nothing
out here, no spikes.
And then on the
next trial, you'll
see increased depolarization
and a place field.
On the next lap, these
are current injections
to check series resistance.
And the place field is there.
I think I got one more.
I'll do one more lap.
There it is, a nice place
field that's developed.
And then the animal
actually forgets to stop,
and the place field
is even smaller.
OK, so here's all of
the data, all the laps.
You can see, the first
10 trials, nothing.
Then plateau potential goes off.
There's no action potentials
or anything before.
You know, of course,
there's something going on
with this giant calcium spike.
And then afterwards,
there's a place field
that stays for the
additional 20 minutes
the animal's on the track.
And that's what the plateau
looks like at the soma.
It's basically a
50 or 60 millivolt,
500 millisecond long
calcium channel mediated
action potential
out on the dendrites
that propagate semi-actively
throughout the entire neuron,
broadcasting this global signal.
And here are these average
of these trials in gray.
And now we've bent
them in space.
There's a little bit
of time bends as well.
So you can see before.
And here's after the plateau.
You can see that there's a very
large ramp of depolarization.
So these are the VMs that
have been median-filtered.
That takes the spikes off.
And so you can just see
this underlying ramp
of depolarization, quite large.
In this case, we can
subtract these two things
and use a time base
based on the running.
During this one trial, when
the plateau potential went off,
it's referenced to that.
So it takes 4 seconds to
run from the very beginning
of the track to the
plateau and then
another 2 or 3 seconds from
the plateau to the end.
And then what you
can see then is--
so this is just a subtraction
of these two traces--
that this change in
the membrane potential
is covering about 6 seconds.
So it's a multi-second
long plasticity--
and that it is also asymmetric
and that it's projecting
further back than forwards.
And you can see that the peak
is actually shifted as well.
So it produces the second
thing that I showed you.
First of all, it's abrupt.
It's abrupt because
these plateau potentials
are so strong.
Bam, one time and you
get a place field.
You get all the plasticity.
It causes the place
field to shift back
because of this asymmetric
plasticity kernel, OK?
And then it's operating
on the seconds time scale.
And depending on how fast
the animal is running,
the width will also
vary accordingly.
All of this can be
blocked by, again,
NMDA receptor antagonists, both
in vivo and in vitro, as well
as calcium channel blockers.
Here's from the population.
Again, it's asymmetric,
covering multiple seconds.
These are all cells that didn't
have really much of a ramp.
We call them silent cells
because they're silent.
But not only that, they
don't have much, even
a subthreshold change in
the membrane potential.
So about 2/3 of these, we've
actually injected current into
to drive the plateau potentials.
So if we have a cell like
this and we inject current
somewhere else, then when
a cell that has already
has a place field, then
the initial place field
will get smaller.
Let's say we inject
a current here.
The initial place
field will get smaller,
and this part would
increase in depolarization.
So the plasticity is
not just a potentiation.
It's also a depression.
It's bidirectional,
and they're happening
both at the same time.
And you can see that here.
If there's already
a place cell--
and we either add plateau
potentials or one happens
spontaneously-- then you can
also see, in addition to less
potentiation, you get this
obvious depression component
as well, this negative change
in the membrane potential.
OK, so as I'll show
you in a second,
that means that the sort
of equilibrium amount
of plasticity that
you're going to get
is dependent upon the weights
that are already there,
the current weights in the
vector of this one cell.
So this is a place cell because
there's a depolarization.
This depolarization is
there because the weights
of these inputs are higher.
So now they can be
depotentiated, if you will.
All right, so here's
the cartoon there.
And we'll start off with just
sort of the basic Hebbian idea.
Here's the postsynaptic cell.
Here's the presynaptic cell,
correlated input, output.
You get plasticity.
We call this plasticity that
I've just showed you BTSP,
Behavioral Time Scale
Synaptic Plasticity.
And it requires
additional components.
One is a new compartment.
We need an apical dendrite.
And we also need a
new voltage signal,
instead of just having
an output signal that's
driving the plasticity
changes in the weights.
We're going to have a
plateau potential, which
is more or less solely
responsible for producing
plasticity.
It's not really
an output signal.
It's just a plasticity signal,
just a plasticity signal.
And then we're going to need an
additional input whose job is
mainly to drive the
plasticity through plateau
potential initiation.
OK, and then we're also going
to need some biochemical signals
to stretch this
thing out in time,
some filters of both the
synaptic input and the plateau
potential.
I'll just tell you
that we've been
trying to figure these out.
It's not easy, and we really
haven't made any progress.
That's the bottom line on that.
It's biochemistry, and that's
a little out of our wheelhouse.
And this is what
we're talking about.
If you get too down
in the wrong layer,
then things start
to go sour on you.
But hopefully, somebody else
can figure these things out,
because this is
still theoretical.
There's very little evidence
of these biochemical signals.
Now, I'm told [INAUDIBLE]
lab has published something
recently with Fred--
Frank Polo that
showed that there
may be an involvement
of calcium release,
calcium-induced calcium
release that may be involved
with this instructive signal.
Anyway, the cartoon
equation is here.
The change in the
weights is-- basically,
here's the heart of the matter,
the overlap of these two
biochemical signals, OK?
And so this determines
which synapses--
this is to pick which
synapses are going to change.
Exactly which
direction and how much
is dependent on the
overlap as well.
And then how far away-- this
is the potentiation component
here.
In this case, if the
potentiation-- these
are the weights that
are already there.
This is the current weight.
If it's high, of course,
then this potentiation
is going to be small.
If it's low, it
can be quite large.
And then there's just
the sort of balance
of this by the depression
component, which, again, is
scaled by the current weights.
Here's the paper,
Aaron's paper in eLife,
where the real equation lives.
And you can go and see that.
Yeah?
Is that enough?
That's the plasticity.
And now, some details--
I hope you like details--
on this instructive pathway,
and where is it coming from,
what's it doing, and what
kind of signal is it.
And so we knew
from the past work
and just sort of bloody
obvious anatomy where to look.
Entorhinal cortex, layer three,
neurons are pyramidal cells.
And they project a pathway that
almost exclusively innervates
the distal apical
tuft of these cells,
where this plateau
potential is initiated.
So Christine is going to do
an optogenetic experiment.
Now, she doesn't want to
blast the whole network.
She's trying to make a subtle
change so that the behavior
doesn't change.
And this is a loop, somehow.
It's not very direct, but
the EC and the hippocampus
are tied together, so she
doesn't want to inadvertently
change the afferent input,
the feedforward input as well.
So she's going to use a
retrograde virus to just infect
the EC cells that are
sending their axons
into this particular
region of the hippocampus.
She's also going to
infect and express
GCaMP in that same
region and record
from this population
of pyramidal cells,
put a light fiber
in, that you see,
to activate the archaerhodopsin
or at least the control
conditions, just cells
that are expressing tomato.
There's a light fiber.
You turn the light on around the
reward location, run the animal
and do everything normal, and
there's basically no effect.
You can see the
overrepresentation
in the middle.
And then in the test group
then with the archaerhodopsin,
she has more or less
inhibited the activity
of a small subset of
EC cells and changed,
removed the adaptive
change, the plasticity
in the CA1 hippocampal
region, OK?
Manipulate an external region
and change the plasticity
in this one region.
Really nice.
And you can see, that's
quantified there.
OK, so something's
going on in the EC.
It's somehow sending
some input that's
helping to drive or direct
this plasticity in CA1.
Next step is to record
from these axons
and see what kind of
activity they have.
Bottom line is that
there's about 5%
and maybe less
than 10% that shows
some decent spatial selectivity.
But most of them
are these kind of
crappy, sloppy,
place-specific cells
that have some specific firing
at a particular location
in the world.
You can see, here's
one cell, many trials.
Position that I
didn't label here.
It is position.
And you can see that there's a
stochasticity to this firing.
It's a little bit weird, OK?
And so that led
us to try to look
at the distribution of these
on times and off times.
And it's true that you need
hundreds of these openings,
and there's only 20
cells out of 1,000
that we had this
many transitions.
But in those cells, there is
an exponential distribution
of the on and off
times of these cells.
So bottom line is, there's
some moderate tuning,
moderate spatial
tuning of the EC input,
with hints of some kind
of nonstandard activity.
OK, so here's another hint
Here's all of the
800 cells for this.
We're still in the
same environment
that I showed you before.
And here's the average of the
odd lab trials, 0, 2, 4, 6, 8,
et cetera.
And you can see they've
been sorted according
to the location of their peak.
And then if we look at the
same cells sorted the same way
but for the intervening
laps, 1, 3, 5, 9,
you can see that there's
some stochasticity there.
They're not very stable.
But there is a little
hint of stability here.
And then if we plot
these locations
for the even-- the peak
locations for the even laps
versus the odd laps, it's
not exactly a shotgun blast,
but pretty close.
There is only 20% of these
cells that have some stability
to their finding.
We made a model of
all this activity
in order to try
to understand how
it would be summed
up postsynaptically
and drive plateau potentials.
Unfortunately, I don't have
time to talk about that.
But I'd be happy to answer
questions about it at any time.
The basic idea is that
we just reproduce--
it's a very simple
model, but it really
captures a lot of the
activity in an amazing way.
2,000 two-state Markov
chains, with a little bit
of tweaking on the transition
probabilities, the activation
probability, to produce
the sloppy tuning.
And then we just
distribute them equally,
uniformly across space.
And that matches the data.
This is basically a
quantification of that.
And the model does
the same thing.
Now, in the model, we
can simulate the mouse
running at a constant rate.
And lo and behold,
there is a constant rate
of plateaus that are
initiated across the track.
Not surprising.
What is interesting about
this is how low this rate is.
So it's 0.5 times 10 to the
minus 3 per second per cell.
So there's 10,000
postsynaptic cells
in this case, 50
laps, 10 seconds.
That gives you about
2,500 plateau potentials,
2,500 new place
cells out of 10,000.
So even at this
incredibly low rate,
you can significantly change
the number of place cells
that are in the population.
Just for comparison, if you
had 40%, 4,000 of your cells
were place cells, and they had
10 hertz firing for 1 second,
you'd get 1,000 times
more action potentials
than you would
plateau potentials.
So it is a very low
rate of occurrence
of plateau potentials,
which fits with the data.
Now, if the animal's obviously
not running at a constant speed
but is slowing down
around the reward site,
here's the real data for that
average of 14 said animals.
And if we use that instead
of this constant rate,
then you can see that the
constant rate of plateau
potentials where an
animal is actually
dwelling for twice as
long around the reward
will give you twice as
many plateau potentials,
twice as many place
cells at that location.
OK, it's that simple.
And so that's our prediction
of what all of this activity
should give you in terms
of a representation in CA1.
Here's the actual
representation in CA1 in black,
and now this is in gray.
You can see that, yeah, it's in
the right place, it's two-fold,
but the data is actually
a three-fold increase.
And there is a significant
correlation here.
Now, you can say, oh, well,
this was a very simple model.
You're lucky to
have gotten that.
And that's pretty
much what we said.
But there is a difference.
And that's what I was
going to show you here.
There's actually a
little more tuning
of-- the cells around the
reward site are actually
a little bit more tuned.
And maybe that's
what's going on there
or maybe we should just
count our lucky stars
and move on, which
is what we did.
So bottom line is, there's
a uniform distribution
of these moderately tuned cells.
So that, plus the running
behavior of the animal,
basically explains
the change or the type
of distribution of
place cells that we
see in the CA1 representation.
Now, it also
suggested to us that--
you can remember, the
somatosensory cues
were uniformly distributed
across the track.
So we thought, maybe that
uniform distribution of the EC
activity is representing
that uniform distribution
of the cues in the environment.
And so we're going to
switch and try to test that.
We're going to remove all the
cues, and have a blank belt,
and just use a light
stimulus 50 centimeters
in front of the reward.
So it's predictive, and
it's strong, it's novel.
The animal's never seen this.
It's a flashing light right
in its eyes, 10 hertz.
You can see that the
licking behavior is
subtly changed, but
not too dramatically,
but that the running
behavior is quite different.
So here's what I just showed
you in black for environment A.
And now, in environment
B, the animal
starts to slow down
around the light stimulus,
and then just continues to
gradually slow, and then
continue on after the reward.
So what do we get from the EC?
Now 800 cells.
Again, the same idea.
Here is the even trial,
the odd trials, and then
the average of the even trials.
You can again see that there's a
lot of stochasticity still left
in this.
But you can see the shadow here.
Now there's about three or five
times as many of these cells.
And again, on this
plot here, right
at the site of the light that
we didn't see before, here
this is quantified again.
There's about a
four-fold increase
in the density of the EC
cells whose peak activity
is around the light.
There's the model in
the lighter colors,
which are difficult to see.
So that's the model.
And then we do the same
thing with the actual running
versus the constant.
Here's the prediction
of the plateaus
in the postsynaptic population.
You can see that
there is a difference.
Again, the running is
making a difference.
But because it's
not just as distinct
as it was before in
the environment A,
there's not as big
of a difference.
And really, there's a
big change in the density
of plateaus around the light.
That kind of tapers
off slowly as you go.
Now, so that's the prediction of
what the CA1 should look like,
the distribution of
place cells in the CA1
in this new environment.
Here it is.
You can see the
overrepresentation there.
Here it is quantified.
There's about a two, three-fold
increase in the CA1 place
cells around the light.
Less of an effect, maybe
75% increase verses
two to three-fold increase in B.
Here are the prediction,
in light, colored red,
from the model and then
the actual from the CA1
data, in the darker color.
Again, there's a significant
correlation between those two.
So it looks like
then that the EC
is adjusting itself, its
activity to the density
or the distribution of relevant
cues in the environment
and using that as
a training signal
or teaching signal to tell the--
to shape the type
of representation
that's present in CA1.
All right, last slide.
What kind of instructive
signal is this?
Is it an error
signal like we would
expect like in the Purkinje
cells in the cerebellum?
So here's something that
I didn't show you before.
Here's the number or the
fraction of place cells,
new place cells, that are
appearing during the trial, OK?
So you can see, in these
sections of 25 laps,
that about 3/4 of the
cells that are going
to appear within
the first 25 trials.
And then this drops like a
rock, such that by 50 trials,
there's essentially very
little plasticity left.
OK, so if this were
an error signal,
we would expect it to track this
same sort of plasticity profile
here.
Instead, our measure of EC
activity in both environments
stays relatively constant.
So this suggests to us that this
is not an error signal coming
in from the internal cortex
and that it's probably
more like a desired or target
signal that's coming in.
And so we can make
the control system
analogy, the weak analogy,
again, where we have--
here's the components
of this here.
Again, the basis
set comes up from--
so there's a feedforward
input from a CA3
of already tuned place cells.
And then there's a target coming
in from the entorhinal cortex.
There's population
activity in CA1
that's fed back through
somatostatin positive O-LM
interneurons who, again,
exclusively innervate
the tuft of these
pyramidal cells in CA1.
This is obviously
an inhibitory input.
And so the apical dendrite
tuft of these cells,
this distal region
of the tree, is
acting like a comparator
for these two activities
in two different
brain regions, OK?
The activity in the
entorhinal cortex
is compared with the activity
in the CA1 via this feedback
inhibition.
And if the target
exceeds the inhibition,
the actual, then
there's an error local
in each individual
pyramidal cell,
and that error is the
plateau potential.
The plateau potential
then produces plasticity.
That changes the
actual CA1 activity.
OK, and so if we
look at this in time,
we remove the real data
and put the cartoon up--
that's always nice--
we can see, the activity
from the target, from the EC
is up here, where the
activity in CA1 is down here.
There's a difference
in the activity.
This produces a large
amount of plasticity
in CA1 in plateau
potentials that
increases the activity in or
just brings it closer in space
to the target.
That reduces the plasticity
and turns everything off.
So as these two activities
approach each other,
this reduces the error signal
in the individual local regions
of CA1 pyramidal cells and
cuts the plasticity off.
All right, so that's it.
There it is in space, same idea.
I'll spare you this.
Basically, it's that it appears
that the entorhinal cortex
in this case is
collecting external input
and internal input from self
motion and maybe decision
making areas or
something and producing
a kind of quick and dirty
estimation of what's
important in the world.
And that's using--
and then sending out
targets based upon this sort of
quick and dirty understanding
about the aspects of the world
to train the hippocampus,
which in the end
shapes itself depending
on what the hippocampus and
what the EC thinks is important.
And because all
of this plasticity
produces shifts in
the place fields,
these are now predictions.
And so one of the ideas is,
actually, these predictions
may then be targets
themselves that
get sent, broadcast
throughout the entire brain
to help it learn as well.
All right, so let me
mention Christine.
She did almost everything
that I showed you today.
And she's your neighbor
now up at Brandeis.
She's very talented.
Look her up some time.
And then Sachin did
some of GCaMP imaging.
Yiding and another student
in the lab, of course,
with Katie, did all of
the wholesale recordings.
And Randy keeps things running.
We still have a lot
of good interactions
with our old
colleagues at Janelia.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
MARK: Questions for Jeff?
AUDIENCE: Thank you, Jeff.
That was great.
I'm wondering about, given that
the synaptic weight affects
the expression of
BTSP, when you expose
the animal to a second
new environment,
is there a relationship
in the same cells
of their new
preferred place field?
JEFF MAGEE: Is there a
relationship with what?
AUDIENCE: In the-- if you
have new place fields forming
in that second environment,
do you see a correlation
in the previous place
field location--
JEFF MAGEE: A prior memory.
Yes, we're looking at that.
That's all I can say.
That's what Sachin's working on.
MARK: Very savvy, Jeff.
Nice save.
JEFF MAGEE: I
can't say anything.
He'd kill me.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank you, Jeff.
That was really interesting.
This rapid dropoff in
place field formation
that happens like--
you get a lot and then
suddenly there's very little.
Is that because the entorhinal
cortex is sending out
fewer blasts?
Or is that because the blasts
are not being registered or not
doing anything?
JEFF MAGEE: Well, so
probably, just the way
that I expressed this
made it look a little more
jumpy than it is.
This is in blocks, OK?
So it's 25 then 25 trials.
But the point is that the EC
activity really isn't changing.
I just showed you
a very simple sort
of overall sum of the average,
but the population vector
isn't changing much
either as the animal goes
through the entire session.
So it has to be
something else that's
turning the plasticity off.
And that's where the control
system thing comes in, where
the feedback from the O-LM
interneurons which innervate
the plateau--
these are somastatin positive
cells, like Martinotti cells--
actually shuts down all the
plasticity, the plateaus.
Nothing changes in the EC.
It still thinks, OK, this
is what you should be doing.
AUDIENCE: But if
you took the mouse
and you put it in a
different environment,
like after 25 trials,
then it would still
be able to learn
the new environment.
I mean, it could
learn constantly.
It just doesn't like to learn
more in the same environment.
Is that--
JEFF MAGEE: That's correct.
And the idea would be just
that the activity of CA1
is approaching the target, OK?
And so if you put it
in a new environment,
then the target would
change, and that
would drive new plasticity.
And so this is
oversimplified, OK?
There's obviously other
things, attentional modulation
and other things like that,
that are going to be involved.
And this is the most
theoretical part of it.
We don't really know
what's shutting it off,
but this is our theory.
And Aaron's made a model of
this in his paper as well,
and it works.
And so that's the
idea, Bartlett,
that there's some component
within the network that's
shutting the plasticity off as
the activities come together.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
So you discovered a new
type of plasticity, right?
The BTSP, in vivo.
People have been trying
to look at plasticity
in vitro and slices
for many, many years.
So what is the
implication of this?
Do you expect that we will find
many more different plasticity
rules that we couldn't
find before in vitro?
Or can you tell us a little
bit why you're able to do this?
JEFF MAGEE: I think
there are enough
plasticity in vitro rules.
Hopefully we won't
find too many more.
This one is in vivo.
This one shows up in vivo.
We haven't done the LTD, the
depotentiation portion of it,
but we need to.
Hopefully, other
people will start
looking at other brain
areas, the neocortex.
It'd be interesting
to see if this
is present in other
pyramidal based circuits.
Like Bartlett showed you,
this is a canonical theme.
It's the same circuit
here as it is everywhere.
So this could happen.
Like, your 5-cells are
a little bit different.
They're like twice as long and
there's more complicated stuff
going on.
So it would be really
interesting to see
if it's going on there.
Now, we'll tell
you, we've looked
at least in vivo in the
previous hippocampal stage,
and this is also there.
There's a plateau-based,
seconds-long plasticity
that's responsible for
place fields in CA3.
We've toyed around with other
pyramidal-- subiculum, things
like this, and it seems
to be there as well.
So this is--
I think, at least
in the hippocampus,
it's established now, and
multiple labs have seen it.
The question, I think,
is how widespread it is.
It going to be just hippocampus?
Is it going to be neocortex too?
Just pyramidal cells?
How about the granule cells?
How about stellate cells?
Things like that.
You know, I would encourage
everybody to do this.
It's not the easiest
thing in the world
to get a calcium
spike in a slice.
It takes modulation,
and then you've
got to deal with all
this other changes,
constantly changing conditions,
if you dump muscarine
on or something like that.
And so we may have to
refine the conditions.
But I would still-- whoever
is interested in this--
this is a very different
form of plasticity
and learning than standard
Hebbian kinds of things
that all of us, really, myself
included, studied for 50 years.
So it's worth looking into.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MARK: One more question.
You.
AUDIENCE: I thought
it was the onset
of this phenomenon [INAUDIBLE]
JEFF MAGEE: That's cool, yeah.
AUDIENCE: And even for
an engineered signal,
usually it starts gradually,
maybe like just [INAUDIBLE] So
the fact that it's so discrete--
any kind of ideas
or speculation?
JEFF MAGEE: Well, so
it's only discrete in
the individual components, OK?
I mean, so it still occurs over
50 trials, tens of minutes.
And it is only discrete
and individual cells,
which in the past, with the
Hebbian kinds of plasticities,
STDP and all of these
things, it would
take dozens of these trials
in the individual cells.
So not only would the overall
population be slowly evolving,
but the individual neurons
within the population
would be slowly expressing
this plasticity as well,
which may be very
important behavior--
developmentally, to develop
these different receptive
fields.
Probably, it is doing something
Hebbian over many weeks
or something like that.
But in this case, it
is abrupt and sudden
within the individual neurons.
And that allows the
whole population
to evolve more rapidly, but
not over the individual.
We're only talking
a few tens of cells
within the whole population
per trial, something like that.
AUDIENCE: We know
this, but then it's
really hard to find the
growth of the population.
JEFF MAGEE: Well, so this is
the level of the population.
It's not as sharp.
It just looks like it here.
This is 50 trials in.
Two points, but we've
done it this way.
And what does correlate with
this is that licking behavior.
So if you plotted these
two versus the evolution
of the licking, the number of
the fraction of licks outside
of the reward site, they
map almost perfectly.
Now, we don't like to--
I don't really like to talk
about that in the paper
or anything like that
because then it's obvious,
you should do that experiment.
And we don't really
want to try to block--
other people have already
done that experiment.
It's hard to block.
Hippocampus is this
huge sprawling thing,
and to actually manipulate the
whole thing is not that easy.
And so we haven't done that.
But other people have.
OK, thanks a lot.
MARK: Thanks to Jeff again.
[APPLAUSE]